est-ce que vous pouvez regarder la
caméra et fer plat
[Musique]
bonjour jean pierre petit bonjour
d'autres vous remercie de m'avoir
accordé cet entretien chez vous à aix en
provence
même si vous vous connaissent déjà
pourriez vous vous présenter et nous
dire pourquoi nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui je suis un scientifique
je vais travailler dans plusieurs
domaines différents mais enfin le thème
de notre interview aujourd'hui s'est
plutôt mes travaux en astrophysique à
cosmologique mal voilà vous allez
principalement nous parler de votre
modèle cosmologique janus on va aborder
les questions de sciences ont aussi
abordé les questions de croyance donc je
signale à nos spectateurs que vous avez
une chaîne youtube vous invite tous à
aller consulter les vidéos de jean
pierre petit notamment sa série vidéo
sur le modèle janus qui représente le
noyau dur de vos travaux actuels vous
allez également publié plusieurs livres
tous les liens sont dans la description
on va rentrer tout de suite dans le vif
du sujet à savoir la présentation de
votre modèle janus où je précise que je
n'ai pas une formation scientifique et
qu'à ce titre je vous inviterai à
vraiment simplifier autant que faire se
peut d'autant que je pense que c'est
aussi ce que nos spectateurs attendent
jean pierre petit première question
pourriez vous me présentez votre modèle
janus comme si j'avais 8 ans première
chose quoique il faut dire pourquoi
c'est un modèle pourquoi créer un modèle
alors notre modèle que sont logiques
depuis les travaux d'einstein s'est basé
justement sur cette relativité générale
cette relativité générale et une belle
équation qui pilote tout ça avec fait
que on remplace les actions à distance
par les forces pendant je maîtrise les
terrains alors lac chose c'est que on
s'est aperçu années 70-80 qu il manquait
de la masse peut-être que les veaux
spectateurs connaissent un petit peu ce
problème par exemple dans les galaxies
et le soleil étant trop vite le soleil
tourne 3 200 kilomètres par seconde il
devrait tourner à 130
donc il ya un excès de vitesse et la
force centrifuge c'est qu'il a dû se
faire la malle depuis longtemps donc les
galaxies tournent trop vite et donc à ce
moment là pour arriver à garder leur
cohésion il faut une matière
supplémentaire et ça fait quatre cinq
six fois là bas ce qu'on observe donc on
avait créé ce concept de missiles masse
de masse manquante et après on
l'appelait de matière sombre et pendant
des décennies on a considéré que ceci
était une évidence que cette masse
devaient exister parce que c'est pas
possible autrement quoi juste pour que
ce soit bien clair donc on constate
qu'il manque de la masse dans l'univers
on imagine que sans doute vous grâce à
des calculs et de là on en déduit le
concept de matière noire pour expliquer
la masse mouvante cette matière dans la
réalité du coût observé ben vous voyez
le question de conscience on on explique
beaucoup de choses en mettant des mots
par exemple qu'est ce que c'est
savez c'est comme la les somnifères qui
ont une vertu dont missive
on est dans le molière quoi alors qu'est
ce que c'est que la bad garçons c'est la
dark matter khl sabots à la femme au et
en 2011 il ya eu une autre catastrophe
tout dacourt s'était passé de l'univers
accélérait vous avez un univers en
expansion qui normalement cette
expansion se ralentit et tout d'un coup
il ya trois jeux libres us qui ont
montré que votre soeur s'est accéléré
alors pour ça il fallait quelque chose
d'autre qu'on appelait l'énergie noire
reste énergie noire
c'est elle qui fait que les locaux
soient s'accélère alors on a mis tout ça
dans ma note cosmologique et ça a donné
ce qu'on appelle le modèle lambda cdm
cdm ça veut dire côte dark matters est
une matière semble mystérieuse froide
puis lambda c'est le pouvoir et plus ils
du vide
alors si on essaye de sortir de ce genre
de choses là une idée que des gens ont
eu dans les années 50 c'est penser
qu'ils puissent y en a des masses
négatives dans l'univers malheureusement
quand on met ces masses négatif dans la
cosmologie c'est une catastrophe parce
que on obtient des lois l'interaction
qui sont aberrantes
donc il ya une chose qui fait qu'on peut
difficilement expliquer et quand on
prend le modèle cosmologique
il est concrétisé par l'équation
d'einstein eh bien c'était cautionnant
contient la loi de newton cela lorsqu'on
lui demande qu'est ce que tu as dans le
ventre
répond mais quand deux masses rencontre
elle s'attire avec une loi françois la
mère du carré de la distance
alors maintenant si on met des masses
négative et qu'on pose la question à ce
modèle edge daniel la réponse et lorsque
les masses multibras contumace négative
la masse positif fiche le corps
poursuivi par la masse des victimes on a
progressé
tex avery ouais c'est très taxe fait
alors j'espère je me suis pas trompé
j'ai bien ça oui je les masses positive
qui s'en va poursuivre la masse négative
et on a appelé ça le phénomène run away
renée ouais ça veut dire partir au loin
alors encore on a mis un mot alors voyez
une chose quand même c'est que en
physique il ya un principe fondamental
qui est le principe d'action réaction
merci attire bébé attira s'effondre
c'est un des fondements de notre
physique et là on a une violation du
principe d'action de réaction ces
particules typhus fréquence et là en
plus l'homme c'est absurde c'est qu'elle
accélère indéfiniment mais l'énergie se
conserve l'énergie cinétique srec
l'énergie cinétique c'est un milieu les
deux mais comme il ya une masse qui est
légitime bon alors la question c'est est
ce qu'on accepte d'intégrer une chose
pareille dans le modèle
alors vous avez des gens comme l'anglais
jamie farnese comme le français lui
briel chardin et qu'ils disent oui au on
va intégrer sur le québec dans des
articles vous trouverez l'étrange
comportement de masse négative alors il
ya aussi une chose se dire non ça je
passerais s'adressent ils excluent la
physique à la sema c'est très compliqué
parce que si on veut sortir de cette
chose là et bien il faut sortir du
modèle de cheval il faut considérer que
l'équation d'einstein
c'était une des deux équations d'un
système de deux équations qui monnaient
genius alors oui proposer quelque chose
qui va au delà les slides qui intègre le
modèle bien seules communes et à c'est
pas commun d'avoir comme en face on se
dit tout de suite en tout cas d'un point
de vue extérieur évidemment que
prétendre dépasser einstein
ça paraît très prétentieuse amarré après
un peu fou mais vous
vous expliquez sais que c'est pas un
long contre en fait agi seul mais
simplement vous complétez vous apporter
la partie la partie en corse
ben vous savez toute façon dans cette
modélisation des choses il ya toujours
un modèle qui fait comme les poupées
russes qui finit en beauté par exemple
vous prenez la loi de newton et bien la
mécanique qui nous soignent elle c'est
une partie de mes crédits que les dates
chanteuse s'est pas faite consistait à
dire newton c'était trompe l'oeil voilà
et là c'est pareil ça veut pas dire le
choc j'ai trompé sa pelouse c'est une
partie de cette dynamique
alors c'est dit mme ebelle à une chose
particulière l'accélération de cosmique
où vous reproduire les exemples des
affiches à venir
aristote s'est elle trompée sur tout
mais il a aussi permis ensuite il a basé
là il a donné une assise à la science
donc tu aurais pas eu de science telle
qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui sans
aristote
mais si on compare avec notre savoir
actuelle évidemment on va dire mars
c'était s'était trompé il vous combinez
ya une chose c'est que quand on crée un
modèle qu'est ce qu'on attend de ce
modèle
on attend qu'ils aient confirmé
observationnelles par exemple moi je
vois qu'il ya un type qui vient de
publier un article à français on
explique la matière sombre
c'est fait avec des minitrous noirs
pourri morio alors premièrement il n'y a
pas de modèle pour expliquer comment ça
c'est un secret il n'y a aucune
observation possible donc là voilà ce
sont des spéculations que tu as dit que
d'un janus qui croient qu'il ya dix-neuf
aspect observationnelles qui colle donc
c'est vrai qu'elle a un deux trois
quatre cinq on se dit que c'est quand
même intéressant clé il ya en 92 quand
on a sorti la structure spirale
galactiques avec un film c'était
impressionnant
alors il ya beaucoup de choses que vous
dites qu'ils anticipent très largement
sur les prochaines questions donc ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on en garde qu
on regarde certains éléments côté pour
la suite comme ça au moins on va essayer
de mettre un petit peu d'ordre pour que
tout le monde puisse nous suivre un fil
n'hésitez pas à vous répétez ainsi
jamais c'est nécessaire donc vous avez
dit que aujourd'hui on utilisait un
modèle standard qu'on appelle le modèle
lambda cdn vous l'avez expliqué et ce
modèle donc présente des lacunes c'est
ce qui commande eux c'est ce qu'ils nous
il a à le dépasser alors j'ajoute quand
même pour nuancer un petit peu les
choses pour qu'on ne soit pas déformée
que aucun modèle à ce jour n'expliquent
tous que c'est tout à fait normal de
trouver des anomalies des points de
faiblesse dans un modèle cosmologique
mais je vous entendu plusieurs fois dire
que la recherche en cosmologie qui est
innée depuis 60 voire 70 ans peut être
plus
d'où ma question quels sont les
principaux problèmes dans le modeste en
armes
les principaux problèmes qui nous oblige
à envisager un nouveau modèle voyez est
ce que c'est une réponse de dire ce qui
provoque l'accélération de l'expansion
c'est le voir plus évident
vous savez il ya une époque où on se
demandait ce qui faisait monter même le
mercure dans les baromètres et vous vous
rappelez je crois que c'est un excellent
italia qui a expliqué ça mais avant on
disait pas c'est simple c'était la
nature a horreur du vide
alors quand vous faites à tubes mais qu'
il ya le vide le mercure monte nature et
l'horreur du vide on la mesure est pour
vous une à chiffrer on disait même que
elle croît avec l'altitude et xavier
donc là tout à coup un type a dit non
c'est plus ça c'est la pression
atmosphérique les modèles mercure bon
voilà donc là la performance d'un modèle
c'est son poids explicatif alors quand
vous prenez le modèle lord acdl mais
quelques défauts qu'il a c'est que il a
tout les phénomènes à des objets
inconnus
par exemple cette matière sont donc
c'est parce que c'est alors
immédiatement évidemment les physiciens
sont remis à chercher comment on
pourrait
identifier cette matière sont donc par
exemple avec les accélérateurs de
particules ont fabriqué des protons et
d'antiprotons des tas de choses on a
cherché à monter l'énergie de ces
particules pour fabriquer ce qu'on
appelait les super particules et parmi
celles ci il y avait une particule qui
s'appelle neutre à lino on n'a pas
réussi à la fabriquer avec les
accélérateurs c'était l'échec complet
quoi et à ce moment là on s'est dit bon
ben si on n'arrive pas à mettre en
évidence l'existence de ces objets on va
peut-être pouvoir les les piéger dans
des pareilles alors comme les
interactions est extrêmement faible on a
envisagé de se protéger -sous 1400
mètres de roche
donc il ya eu une installation dans le
tunnel du mont sli une autre en italie
d'un tunnel du mont sasso justement où
on les chercheurs s'étaient mis à l'abri
de ces particules de rayons cosmiques
identité un bruit de fond alors pour
garder un petit peu ces choses là bastos
a tristement comique du wanted qui dit
comme ceux des 22 ans qu'on cherche un
mois plus tôt ça fait maintenant 22 ans
qu'on cherche sa matière noire dans le
laboratoire souterrain de modane
depuis le temps qu'on recherche on doit
être proche du lieu où elle enregistre
alors j'ai obligé d'intervenir là c'est
quand même assez incroyable c'est à dire
que bon on a une hypothèse
qui est donc l'existence d'une matière
sombre et on se dit on va tenter de
vérifier cette hypothèse
mais pour que ça puisse expliquer
l'observation et finalement on essaye en
essayant des seuils et ça marche pas et
on se dit que parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on essaye on doit bientôt y
arriver mais pas la solution mais ça
c'était un tag axe est français qui ait
dit ça mais l'italienne par exemple
l'italien entrepris de piéger ces
particules avec du xénon avec un liquide
alors à l'essai avec un kilo de lait
n'ont rien alors allez si les 10 kg de
graines en rien excéder 100 kg de jen
aurélia donne d'excellents toujours rien
et quelle est l'idée s'est dit au début
de la prochaine fois alors il y avait
une bourse à l'urss avant l'effondrement
il n'y avait pas assez de communisme en
urss
nan mais le truc pas iops gates il ya un
numéro spécial de pour la science qui
est sorti récemment et là dedans il ya à
l'arrière du lou qui fait un commentaire
en disant qu' on va arriver à une
situation où le bruit de fond duo
neutrinos va devenir nuls s'en foutent
de nous perdre un de roche
donc on va dire ça existe mais on ne
peut pas la mettre en évidence et qui
ont il faut voir les vidéos il ya
l'italienne qui est un talent a le blues
quoi tu te dis c'est complètement fou de
chercher un truc comme ça pendant aussi
longtemps en se demandant si ça existe à
la zone nettement on ne peut pas
continuer à chercher pendant autant
d'années
c'est quelque chose qui ne se montrent
pas est-ce que c'est frustrant
ou est-ce que ça me tue simplement
l'idée de mettre autant d'énergie dans
cette expérience elle va éventuellement
rien trouvé c'est très c'est très
frustrant
alors moi je pense que ça n'existe pas
je conjectures qui trouveront rien
est-ce que vous avez d'autres exemples
d'anomalies ou en tout cas de deux
lacunes dans le modèle landa cdn qui
pensent enfin qui vous pensez plutôt que
que ce modèle là est dépassé
ben disons c'est pareil dans un mois
nous sommes les nems il y avait sept
cette constance lambda qui repose dès le
pouvoir répulsif de vide et c'est un mot
il ya même pas de théorie c'est que
c'est un concept pouvoir au but vide
alors là encore c'est le principe du
rasoir de calme on a deux théories une
qu'ils disent et mystérieux qui dit je
sais à quoi c'est dû
bon ben alors là alors modèle qu'est ce
que dit le modèle janus mail ou de la
ville us 10 ce qui provoque cette
accélération
c'est de l'anti matière hamas mediative
hélas pas ça fait sens alors justement
on va un peu en vrille on va se
rapprocher progressivement de du détail
de l'explication votre modèle janus donc
dans le prolongement de la question
précédente
et parce que les non spécialistes comme
en auront besoin de la formation claire
qu'est ce que les autres modèles
candidat parce qu'il ya plusieurs
prétendants au titre de modèle
cosmologique et je vous ai souvent
entendu en parler de manière assez peu
tendres
qu'est ce que ces modèles ne permettent
pas d'expliquer et que votre modèle
janice me permet d'expliquer sinon que
les modèles autre que janus en termes de
masse négative alors là ils sont très
primitif filiale l'anglais jamie farr
metz mais lui il garde le fait de rester
dans ce modèle d'acheter donc il a le
phénomène runaways et pour lui c'est le
norway c'est ça qui fabrique les rayons
cosmiques et alors ensuite vous avez
français les voyages hardox qui lui
imagine que c'est de l'anti matière
hamas négative mais alors vous savez
peut-être que auxerre dont on a monté
des grandes manifs comme alpha comme
jebba voirie la pesée l'antimatière sert
qu'on sait fabriquer de l'antimatière on
sait la neutraliser qu'après on va voir
comment elles tombent donc son invité
alors lui il espère que ça va tomber
vers le haut non modèle jalousie pas du
tout je vais tomber vers le bas donc les
mêmes prédictions vous avez récemment
vous avez aussi jaws très importante que
c'est pas mentionner c'est que dans la
cosmologie
on a des particules mais on a aussi des
photons ces photos résiduelles qui
constituent le fond de rayonnement
atteint 7 degré absolu et ces photons et
bien je crois qu'on a mis en évidence en
67 choses comme ça saigne et à
l'animation de la matière et de l'anti
matière primordiale donc 90 et enfin il
ya la pourcentage énorme mais seulement
une particule sera milliards qui a
subsisté c'est vous c'est moi c'est
les atomes de cette pièce donc il doit
doit exister une quantité équivalente
d'antimatière alors où est elle alors à
ce moment là bas les gens vont chercher
et le modèle janus explique que c'est
antimatière belle est parmi nous c'est
de l'art ti matière basses négatives et
on n'observe pas pourquoi parce que les
photons de bastad et il
ils ont une énergie négative ils
admettent les particules de la saga
thing et même des photos énergie
négative et ses photos les quelques pas
donc c'est fc explique la visibilité et
ça explique la nature des objets et ça
c'est une idée qui a été lancé pour la
première fois par le russe andreï
sakharov franc 67
là c'était parfaitement clair donc janus
concrétise geo music man les idées
sakharov alors qu'il n'y a pas de
théorie alternative pas du tout alors là
on est vraiment dans le coeur de notre
présentation du modèle c'est à dire que
bon alors déjà je rappelle que pour ceux
qui se poseraient la question janus
1 pourquoi avoir choisi ce nom modèle
janus on pourrait dire que c'est presque
un clin d'oeil par rapport à sa cadence
puisque qu'est ce que fait sakharov en
1967 il explique qu'il ya deux univers
on a un univers jumeaux ou le temps
valve en verre oi ce moment là le temps
circule du passé le diffuseur mal passée
et le dieu janus dans la mythologie
gréco-romaine
c'est un dieu qui regarde à la fois
culturel et vers le passé voilà le dieu
le dieu des commencements et des fins et
puis d'ailleurs c'est pas tous des choix
du passage et des portes
symboliquement absolument il est
représenté avec les deux visages donc la
tournée dans le passé l'autre nouvelle
il ya une chose que ont regardé c'est
tout à l'heure sur l'écran dans la
presse depuis je janvier on voit
apparaître dans les pages du nouvel
observateur a une énergie mots qui
contient de l'antimatière laquelle va en
sens inverse dans le temps et ça c'est
genius cas et c'est donc un travail qui
est imputée aux canadiens et au rock
est ce que tu vois que tu au courant de
métro je pense que oui
maintenant en tout cas les journalistes
français le sont mais sans me le dire
les qu'il faut absolument précisé le
spectateur sait que ça fait 40 ans que
vous travaillez sur ce modèle là que
vous avez beaucoup de mal à à publier
dans des revues à comité de lecture pour
expliquer les détails de votre modèle
mais que parallèlement à sa manière un
petit peu comme ça qui apparemment
accidentels apparaissent des articles
qui reprennent violer les fondements de
votre modèle un système dit métriques je
vois mon dit aussi en fait ya plusieurs
appellations et voulait pas citer nom
n'est pas cité dans ces articles n'ont
comme son inspiration du même comme mû
comme angie storm existe pas alors que
les personnes qui regardent cette vidéo
actuellement et conscience d'une chose
c'est qu'à part sakharov pour vous avait
déjà parlé de ne jamais tu son nom lever
toujours citées on peut compter sur les
doigts de la main le nombre de
scientifiques qui ont proposé un modèle
du tiff que l'eau n'est janus en tant
que monnaie alternatif vous avez la
fameuse théorie monde monde2 dire modify
newton dynamique pour ça c'est amis
israéliens qui s'appelle mort de kayes
je m'en veulent plus de son nom et lui
il imagine que l'allemagne ou tenait tam
assuré l'un d'eux puis au bout d'un
certain temps ses assurés alors ça
arrive à expliquer des choses mais pas
tout ça explique du confinement des
galaxies mais pas celui des amas civique
on a une sorte de loi de newton qui dans
cette manche avec la distance mais avec
disons que l'équipe l'une ne pèse pas
aussi lourd que l'équipe sera envoyée
donc je sais pas je crois que tu viens
en plus si aucune base ontologique dorée
à l'or alors sans valeur de lire
juste pour pour compléter un petit peu
donc la notion de matières négative de
masse négatif à la notion de masse
négatif ça c'est quelque chose qui va
beaucoup interrogé con j'ai découvert ça
dans vos travaux qui passent eux alors
j'ai défendre un point de vue de novi
sad très naïf comme ça votre rôle sera
maître de m'expliquer moi j'ai appris en
cours de physique que le hamas c'était
la quantité de matière dans un objet et
j'ai aussi appris en mathématiques que
les nombres de 0 à plus infinie c'était
on les appelait les nombres entiers
naturels
sous-entendu bas ce sont les noms blé
oui les nombres qui existent dans la
nature au sens où ce qui est devant nous
c'est positif c'est à dire si j'ai un
objet devant moi j'ai plus un objet qui
est pas moins un objet et donc l'idée de
deux nombres négatifs si je lui trouve
un sens en mathématiques pour traduire
l'idée de pertes par exemple ou de
diminution
tous les collégiens connais ça j'ai
beaucoup plus de mal avec l'idée d'une
masse négatives dans un univers physique
que je pense est par définition positif
mais vous avez quand on vous parlait par
exemple des noms malgé briques avec plus
quelque chose et moi quelque chose alors
on pourrait dire des nombres comme plus
sains plus depuis ce 3 pour moi ça me
parle parce que j'ai un lapin de lapin
trois là voilà qu'est ce que c'est que -
un employé exane moi quelque chose eh
bien il faut revenir à cette notion de
calcul de quelques l'uss dans le temps
lorsqu'un commerçant renvoyait à
l'adjoint pour livrer des objets bien il
adjoint une sphère en en argile à la
terre desquels une petite boule il y
avait autant de boules que d'objets donc
il ne pouvait pas casser la sphère il
peut pas truqué donc quand il arrivait
sur place dans dix ans je viens vous
livrer ce que vous avez demandé ont
cassé la sphère on avait autant de
boules que d'objets ça allait bon là ce
sont des objets positif mais imaginez
que les spurs sont des objets qu'on
livre est au contraire l'équipe seniors
g qui viennent dont il va prendre
livraison
donc il arrive je viens prendre ma
commande ma commande bien c'est tant
d'objets négatif que vous devez me
donnez vous voulez l'art le plus à moins
d'un changement des licenciements alors
maintenant quand on pense aux mosses et
bien c'est à l'aspect comportemental
comportementale ben les masses si l on
tel comportement elles sont positives et
tel comportement elles sont négatives
par exemple ces masses négatives elles
sortent poussé par le mas positive donc
il n'a pratiquement pas dans notre
système solaire
très bien alors là je rebondis
maintenant sur ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure à propos de la prédiction dans
votre vidéo janus numéro 5 vous dit
quelque chose d'absolument fondamentale
bouzid un modèle est intéressant si les
prédictifs oui mais c'est vrai que le
propre d'un la modèle scientifique et
qu'il soit c'est qu'il est capable de
prédire un certain nombre de phénomènes
c'est-à-dire d'anticiper l'observation
et si ces prédictions de se vérifie bien
évidemment c'est un argument de poids
pour sa faveur même si ça ne prouve pas
qu'il aimerait ça prouve qu'il mérite en
tout cas qu'on s'y penche
ou du moins s'il prédit des choses qui
n'étaient pas déjà prédite par d'autres
modèles et al'inverse si les prédictions
du modèle ne se réalisent pas c'est
peut-être le signe qu'il est incorrect
ou au minimum un complet par conséquent
qu'est ce que prédit votre modèle janus
donc pourrions avoir une confirmation
expérimentale dans les années à venir
par exemple que l'antimatière de
laboratoire à tomber vers le bar voilà
une prédiction
alors effectivement il là on prend date
un autre en date les paris sont lancés
si elle tombe vers le haut ça je serais
gêné alors par contre il ya
effectivement deux antimatière il ya une
anti matière de laboratoire king masse
positive et puis l'antimatière
cosmologique et le mas négative mais
celle là elle est entre les galaxies a
effectivement on pourrait peut-être
arriver à le mettre en évidence je
voudrais transporter le
laboratoire à 100 millions d'années
lumière reçue ça assez coûteux quand
même indiqué alors par contre je vais
vous citer une prédiction qui s'est
réalisé ça c'est intéressant
c'est dans les années 90 un moment
j'étais un dialogue avec un referee
anonyme d'une revue il m'a dit qu'est ce
que votre modèle prédit ray alors il ya
une chose c'est que vous savez il ya ce
phénomène qu'on appelle l'effet de
lentille gravitationnelle qui fait qu'il
ya des distorsions d'image comme ça et
quand c'est un effet positif
il savait une lentille convergence ça
qu'on fait converger la lumière si vous
regardez les lumières avec lundi qu une
année encore plus de lumière quand ils
divergent que ça atténue la luminosité
donc moi j'ai dit voilà s'il ya des
objets très lointains comme les galaxies
primordiales
eh bien elles vont apparaître comme des
naines parce que leur lumière sera
affaiblie par les lentilles
gravitationnelles
c'est ce qu'on a trouvé mais quelques
mois après donc effectivement c'était
pas que là on a mis en évidence le fait
que les galaxies avec des redshifts
perrière à cette très distantes avec des
luminosités très faible et à ce moment
là les astres vie des candidats comme
les galaxies naines avec la question
pourquoi se forme-t-il delixi même et
qui après deviennent des annonces et les
gadgi normal voilà une prédiction
ça c'est très bien alors on va on va
passer à les questions peut-être un peu
plus large sur la science donc avant de
passer à ce type de questions est ce que
vous auriez des choses à ajouter sur sur
la progression de votre modèle ou
éventuellement la critique du modèle
standard
là vous avez quartier libre pour
compléter ce que je trouve navrant si
vous voulez le sait depuis 2014 ça fait
six ans j'ai demandé à tous les
séminaires à tous les laboratoires de
france et de navarre à pouvoir présenter
mon travail j'ai aucune en france et
même temps de réponse négative ce qu'une
réponse si vous avez sur internet une
pétition avec douze mille cinq cents
signatures et 4500 messages en demandant
à ce que je puisse présenter mon travail
à la cij une étude de bures-sur-yvette
qui est un petit peu la mecque
oui c'est ça qui était hallucinant on
sait que
travail ça se discute moi je suis choqué
moralement qui est pas de décharge c'est
incroyable oui alors là effectivement je
pense que quel que soit notre notre avis
entre guillemets va souvent sur la
science ne peut pas vraiment parler
d'avis mais même s'il ya des personnes
on va dire si vous avez des
contradicteurs voir les détracteurs dans
le milieu scientifique la base de la
science on va en parler on va être une
partie de cet entretien en parler c'est
quand même le débat celle échange c'est
la confrontation si on voulait utiliser
un mot pompeux c'est la transe
subjectivité c'est à dire la
confrontation des points de vue et pour
que les points de vue se confrontent
encore faut-il qu'ils puissent
s'exprimer en tout cas pour les entendre
donc moi je fais un appel
j'allais dire cela n'aide en tout cas un
appel à toutes les personnes qui
regarderait cet entretien et qui aurait
les moyens qu'elle compte de faire
avancer les choses pour que vous
puissiez publier vos articles sans qu'on
vous renvoie dans vos pénates avec des
excuses parfois un petit peu quand même
j'y arrive quand même publier les
articles c'est dur mais on y arrive là
le problème c'est pas publie les
articles c'est d'arriver à parler d'un
séminaire devant des collègues vous
rendez compte il n'y a pas une réponse
de toute la france pour tous les
observatoires tous les sommes de
visiteurs et toutes ces choses c'est pas
normal
ou alors si à n'importe quelle personne
dans le milieu scientifique qui peut et
qui souhaitent organiser un séminaire et
vous y invite est là mais les lancers
qui n'hésite pas à qui se manifeste à ce
que ben on en est là aujourd'hui c'est
simplement essayer d'accéder à la
visibilité pour confronter les produits
parce que vous n'êtes pas le genre de
scientifiques qui va fuir le débat
enfin du doubs plutôt contraire les
contrôles contre voilà donc peu qu'on se
le dise
alors on avance on peut pas aborder
toutes ces questions d'ordre
scientifique sans se poser un moment
donné la question donc du fonctionnement
même de la science et de sa nature
ce qu'on appelle l'épistémologie donc
épistémologie c'est la branche de la
philosophie qui étudie les conditions de
la connaissance
ça consiste à se demander si je
simplifie que peut-on connaître
or ce que l'épistémologie nous apprend
c'est que la science est évidemment une
méthode mais c'est aussi et surtout un
mode de représentation
les choses dont vont dépendre des choix
et des orientations de recherche
et c'est là qu'on peut introduire la
notion de paradigme dans les sciences
d'un paradigme c'est une certaine
conception du monde
c'est un système de représentation
l'univers est un paradigme par
définition est tout sauf neutre
un paradigme n'est jamais neutre parce
que de chaque parent a dit qu nom va
découler une manière particulière de
poser les problèmes ce qui va déjà pré
déterminer la manière dont on va
répondre à ces problèmes je prends un
exemple que ce soit parfaitement que la
cour nos spectateurs
on peut envisager un paradigme de la
terre plate ça veut pas dire que on
aurait raison considéré que la terre est
plate mais ça veut dire que dans un
modèle de représentation l'univers dans
laquelle dans lequel pardon la terre
serait plaque une simple c'est possible
alors sur cette notion de paradigme je
renvoie le spectateur aux travaux du
philosophe américain thomas skoun
notamment à son livre la structure des
révolutions scientifiques où il explique
bien justement que la science ne peut se
renouveler et finalement progressé
compris d'un changement de paradigme
lorsque le paradigme en vigueur est
épuisée et qui ne permet plus à avancer
la recherche
son arrêt dans la question est-ce que
l'épuisement de la recherche
sociologique que vous décrivez ne
correspondrait pas aux prémices d'un
changement de paradigme
oui et c'est un changement très grave se
passer quand vous prenez par exemple
nous sommes en paradigmatique de 1900
avec l'avènement de la relativité
restreinte et de la relativité générale
ça a été un changement paradigmatique
important mais ça n'a pas bouleversé
l'astronomie par exemple
on est une des bases observationnelles
c'est l avance du père et yves mercure
qui est un truc très très minime donc
simplement l'astronomie classique et moi
nous tenaillait n'expliquait pas ça et
ensuite alpha il expliqué mais ça
flanqué pas tout en l'air alors que là
vous imaginez dire tout d'un coup la
matière somme ça n'existe pas l'énergie
noire ça n'existe pas
mais il ya des milliers d'articles qui
partent en fumée il ya des discours qui
deviennent invalides c'est terrible et
quand vous parlais justement de
paradigme cela consisterait à dire ce
votre masque dont vous parlez quel type
de matière sont pas ce que c'est mais ça
n'est pas de la matière sont est
également un discours que que deviennent
mes propres travaux ben ils valent plus
rien et oui et c'est peut-être ça qui
est l'obstacle le plus important pour
janus c'est que c'est un modèle qui
casse tout
donc le changement de paradigme serait
trop coûteux oui coûteux
réécoutez oui justement pour aller un
peu au fond des choses parce que c'est
l'impression que j'ai en vous écoutant
moi ce dont j'ai l'impression c'est que
les chercheurs en cosmologie serez dans
une sorte de logique de l'entêtement les
avis du modèle standard
ouais mais logique 2 d'obstination
aveugle d'iran le débat rationnel très
compliqué et ça votre votre situation
le démontre ça ne dépensait de serre et
la phrase de sacha guitry
la raison ne peut rien contre
l'entêtement trucks l'idée c'est comme
si on avait tellement investis sur le
modèle standard qu'on ne pouvait plus
faire machine arrière et envisager qu'on
soit plus simplement trompé direction et
que donc on préférait s'entêter dans une
mauvaise direction plutôt que de faire
un pas en arrière pour se réorienter et
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui a été
étudiant en psychologie
ça s'appelle l' escalade de l'engagement
c'est quand on allait trop loin
donc le déploiement d'une action pour
accepter d'avoir eu tort et de revenir
en arrière
il vendra des comptes ces gens qui
cherchent la matière sombre dans leur
mine et or cuit qui en fait c'est avec
une tonne de xénon qui vont ici dit 'on
mais tout d'un coup siro se dit
quand vous voyez ces laboratoires c'est
très important il ya eu de l'argent il
ya des salaires il ya des gens qui sont
là dedans tout d'un coup on ferme en
disant vous avez perdu votre temps c'est
catastrophique et e
là j'ai également envie qu'on aborde la
question de la croyance justement selon
quelle est la part de croyance alors je
vais préciser après ce que j'entends par
croyance mais je vais vous laisser
développer la part de croyances des
scientifiques actuelles dans le modèle
standard puisque ce que vous dites après
tout c'est que centaine d'enseignants
quelque chose finalement qu'il donnera
jamais rien mais pourquoi s'entêter dans
quelque chose qui ne donnera rien ou en
tout cas qui ne répondent pas qui ne
réagit pas à moins d'être animée par une
croyance mais la croyance déjà c'est la
croyance dans la notion de progrès c'est
à dire que on a une certaine façon de
démonter le réel et on va continuer vous
savez ça a commencé avec les atom
on l'a démonté les atom avec des
nucléons les électrons bien mais on a
cassé les nucléons cas alors on s'est
dit on va casser on va casser mais le
problème est ce que c'est ça la voix de
stratégie vous avez quand on s'est mis à
envisager de quoi était fait les les
protons et neutrons on avait la théorie
des quartz et s voilà on a eu une grosse
surprise à les années 70 c'est quoi qui
avait une charge électrique de tiers
donc ça devait se voir dans les
excellentes a tenu et on n'a pas vu donc
autrement dit ce qui est apparu c'est
que les couacs n'existait pas à l'état
libre mais la question est ce que c'est
ça ou est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
faire comme les épices hic de ptolémée
vous qui êtes she loves ça vous rappelle
quelque chose jamais dans les piscines
des polémiques c'est une approche à un
modèle qui était infiniment perceptible
quand ça n'allait pas en rajouter un
cercle et à la fin y avait 48 cercle il
ya une anecdote c'est le l'infante
d'espagne qui est qui suivait un
enseignement est quant à lui a expliqué
fait il ya 10 si dieu l'avait consulté
avant de faire cela j'aurais commenter
quelque chose de plus simple
voilà c'est ce dont parlait d'ailleurs
dans vos premières vidéos janus on a une
remontée en fait aux racines de la
cosmogonie les premières cosmogonie
style
modèle de conception l'univers où
effectivement on avait des résultats qui
pouvait être allé au mieux approximatif
et dans lesquels on rajouter des
éléments de complexification pour que ça
colle vraiment avec observation mais à
la fin ça devenait tellement délirant
que vous avez pu voir ça n'avait pu
alors pour revenir à la croyance dans le
milieu scientifique
ça me semble vraiment très très
important de rappeler que oui les
scientifiques sont autant soumis aux
croyances que les autres et c'est une
erreur gravissime que je pense de croire
que parce qu'on fait de la science on
aurait pouvoir de s'extraire de ces
croyances on s'extrait jamais de ses
croyances
on les façonne pour les faire
correspondre à notre conception de la
rationalité
la preuve c'est que personne ne va rien
en disant je suis quelqu'un d'
irrationnelles et je pense je crois en
des choses sans aucun fondement
tout le monde pense être rationnel tout
le monde pense avoir de bonnes raisons
de croire ce qu'il croit et ça ça me
semble il ya un gros malentendu quand on
parle de de la croyance qui est que
beaucoup de gens confondent de croyance
et croyances irrationnelles
or il ya des croyances très rationnel
d'habitude disait j'ai besoin de croire
que le soleil se lèvera demain même si
dans les faits je ne veux pas en être
certain qu'on sort mais j'ai besoin de
cette croyance qui est une présence très
rationnel parce que sans croyance je ne
peux plus vivre dans un monde qui a du
sens la croyance donne du sens donc une
présence n'est pas forcément une
croyance dans quelque chose de
surnaturel d'irrationnel mais ça ne veut
rien en fait que ce sont des croyances
et là je les cite est un philosophe que
tous les étés titien devrait avoir lu
qui s'appelle charles sanders perth et
qui explique que le phénomène de la
croyance est totalement indépendant du
contenu de la faïence la croyance c'est
le phénomène par l'acte par lequel
j'adhère à une idée non pas parce
qu'elle est vraie mais parce qu'elle
donne du sens à mon identité et qu'elle
me procure une satisfaction
et c'est justement parce qu'elle nous
procure une satisfaction que je vais la
percevoir comme vrai et non pas la nes
et plus je suis en recherche de
satisfaction plus besoin que les choses
aient du sens pour moi
et plus je vais solidifier les croyances
tout
mc rochelle comme des vérités absolues
et au delà la croyance fait ce qu'il y a
il ya le dogmes le dogme n'est pas le
propre des religions que le dogme c'est
la croyance tech que l'idée même qu'on
puisse le remettre en cause nous est
insupportable et donc pour revenir au
sud une autre entretien parmi les les
dogmes indéboulonnable dans la
communauté scientifique 1 les dogues
n'ont qu'on peut pas remettre en cause
sous peine de passer pour un ferrer
comme dirait l'autre il y en a un qu'on
ne peut pas passer sous silence c'est
celui de la vitesse de la lumière qui
est présenté comme une constante unis la
scène donc jean pierre petit vous qui
avez étudié la question qu'en est il de
la vitesse de la lumière
les choses par exemple c'est que j'ai
fait une bande dessinée là dessus qu'ils
s'appellent tout est relatif bon et
c'est vrai que c'est difficile à
expliquer pour l'homme de la rue
qu'est ce qui fait que la vitesse de la
lumière s'impose comme une limite ça
veut pas dire que dans le cosmos il ya
des épices tvo expliqué le cas du flec
attention vous approchez 308 km parce
qu'on arrêtait ne lance la savoie un
vieux métriques
c'est un peu comme des liens je ne peux
pas les plus profondément qu au centre
d'une sphère parvient vraiment une
phrase comme ça vous habitez sur une
espèce de good click id et lui dit je
vous allez très profond bas quand vous
serez vous pourrez pas aller plus loin
ces moments ça alors donc c'est vrai que
à l'intérieur d'un contexte avec des
masses données et bien on ne peut pas
aller plus vite qu'une certaine vitesse
qui l'habitait la lumière c'est
simplement c'est une propriété de
l'espace il y a tout ceci est
entièrement construit une contenus dans
la phrase nous vivons dans un espace
2000 koski ça c'est incompréhensible
pour l'homme de la rue mais tout de
suite ça fait sens maintenant s'il faut
comprendre s'il y en a deux des espaces
comme ça ça c'est sakharov qui commence
par lui dire et les deux univers n'ont
pas nécessairement la même vitesse de la
lumière
c'est en s'intéressant à très
intéressant et je vous laisse pour susi
vous souhaitez c'est à dire que souvent
nous expliquer c'est que la limite de la
vitesse de la lumière
finalement n'est pas une propriété de la
lumière elle même est plutôt une
propriété de l'espace dans lequel se
diffuser avec son contenu avec son
contenu que vous avez des photos
d'énergie positive qui peuvent pas le
plus vite que 308 km forcément mais les
photons d'énergie négative pas aller
plus vite que 3 millions de kilomètres
par seconde il ya facteur 10 voilà donc
à ce moment là
deux lois de la physique sont
différentes ça c'est fascinant et donc
si on révise notre conception du cosmos
on peut du coup envisager une autre
vitesse de la lumière dans tout cas
d'autres potentiels vitesse de la
lumière disant que si tout d'un coup
vous avez un véhicule qui arrive à
inverser sa mars
eh bien il peut franchir des distances
et à ce moment là il a une limitation de
vitesse qui lui laisse une place
beaucoup plus large puisqu'il est dix
fois plus grande et les dix ans ont
raccourci d'un facteur 100 donc il ya
une facteur 1000 sur la durée donc les
voyages interstellaires deviennent
faisable et là est la cause du blocage
total des comités scientifiques parce
que vous imaginez ce que ça soulève dit
à tout d'un coup que les voyages
interstellaires son nom impossible
vous savez qu'on a trouvé des des
milliers d'exoplanètes et maintenant on
trouve des planètes qui ont des
conditions de vie et qui sont semblables
à celles de la terre jeu verra donc à ce
moment là il n'ya plus personne qui dira
nous sommes seuls dans l'univers
il ya forcément des gens donc à semer
mata la dernière barrière l'appareil
avec piste et biologiques dernière c'est
c'est sûr il ya des êtres intelligents
mais il peut pas bien de voir parce que
c'est ça sent trop loin et qu'on peut
pas aller à l'église de linselles que
dis-je abus ce ces noms c'est faisable
c'est faisable sas est une crime absolu
voilà mais là où j'ai l'impression que
beaucoup de personnes vous répondre ça
comme si c'était un argument définitif
c'est que ces personnels on a compris
qu'en fait il s'agissait pas de dépasser
la vitesse de la lumière il s'agissait
d'envisager un espace dans la quête dans
lequel une autre vitesse de la lumière
existent je donne un exemple pas
l'imaginer que vous prenez un trajet il
consiste à les deux comment dire de
marseille et alger
alors marseille et alger vous avez deux
solutions soit vous faites un trajet
aérien
vous êtes limité pendant que vous avez
une loi qui vous interdit d'aller public
avide et du son alors à ce moment là
puisque cabinet du sombre si vous êtes
dans l'air c'est
300 km seconde bon maintenant si vous
êtes dans l'eau à ses 2500 dont vous
avez deux vitesses du sont différentes
alors si vous changez le milieu donc
tout d'un coup quelqu'un émerge à alger
en bien voilà j'ai mis tant de temps
c'est pas possible tu as dépassé la
vitesse du son non pas dans le milieu
j'ai voulu voir là je crois que c'est
clair c'est très clair parfait alors
bien une chose qui perturbe forcément le
philosophe en tout cas les apprentis
philosophes lorsqu'il s'aventure sur le
terrain des descentes de la nature c'est
le statut des mathématiques bon on
connaît la phrase de galilée qui disait
la nature est un livre écrit en langage
mathématique
effectivement c'est facile en tout cas
moi je trouve de de constater à quel
point les mathématiques sont efficaces
pour rendre compte du fonctionnement de
l'univers alors aujourd'hui
bon certains se posent la question de
savoir est ce que c'est l'univers
lui-même qui est de nature mathématiques
autrement dit est-ce que les
mathématiques sur le langage de
l'univers ou bien est-ce que les
mathématiques sont le langage inventé
par l'homme pour faire parler la nature
donc là je suis référence à un discours
détiennent klein tout son propos sur sur
les mathématiques mais en réalité c'est
une question philosophique très ancien
hein parce que ça doit déjà exact ça
doit enfin voilà ça nous ramène à la
querelle des universaux déjà ça nous
ramène à l'opposition platon et aristote
un puisqu'on sait que pour platon le
monde hésite et être était un monde
transcendant donc sensible tandis que
pour aristote bien les concepts sont des
inventions de l'esprit pour rendre
compte du mont sensible mais dans tous
les cas le fait est que si l'univers
n'était pas régi par les mathématiques
on pourrait pas utiliser les
mathématiques pour prédire des
observations que sont logiques je vais
prendre un seul exemple c'est la
découverte de neptune par le verrier en
1846 non pas par l'observation non pas à
la lunette astronomique mais par le
calcul à partir des irrégularités de la
trajectoire d'uranus autrement dit les
les mathématiques ont finalement permis
de découvrir le net une avant qu'on
découvre d'actu
donc la question quel est le statut
des mathématiques dans la recherche
cosmologique le statut des mathématiques
et plus particulièrement dans votre
modèle janus moi je pense il phrase de
mon maître à penser le mathématicien
jérôme sur you qui a d'ailleurs écrit un
livre qu'il n'a jamais publié
malheureusement qui s'appelle grand-mère
de la nature et pour lui les
mathématiques c'est la grammaire de
nature c'est très jeune et que mots
alors s'est-il mois on a eu des
discutions ensemble de ce côté là est la
question c'est est ce qu'il existe des
mathématiques pures
est ce qu'il existe des mathématiques
qui n'ont rien à voir avec leurs ailes
sur liu penser que non je moi je vais
pas trancher là dessus mais c'est vrai
que ça pose des quatre questions parce
que par exemple vous avez pris l'exemple
de le verrier qui a calculé la position
de la planète l'étude mais de nos jours
nous avons avance du public mercure et
imaginons qu'elle stein ne sont pas
venus mais à ce moment là il y aurait à
lever à lévis qui calcule à dire c'est
ce qu'a fait le verrier ne verriez a
fait un calcul en disant c'est dû à une
planète qui s'appelle vulcain qui tourne
près du soleil et qui est plus près que
mercure comme il était très près du sol
et on peut pas l'observer alors on a
essayé désespérément d'observer
quelqu'un vous savez ce qu'on dirait
toujours écouté bien ça on dirait c'est
une dark planète intemporel soi mais oui
mais oui mais ce qu'on sait qu'elle
écrit semons abrapa
voilà bah ça fait rien alors là c'est là
c'est le côté vicié des mathématiques il
considéré je ne me vois pas mais jamais
un mot et voilà tout et tout est réglé
ce que voulait dire l'un de vous me
corrigez 6 me trompe c'est que autant on
peut faire l'hypothèse d'un élément
physique par par un calcul qui voit là
on retrouve quelque chose par le calcul
mais à ce moment là on va le vérifier
ensuite par l'observation mais son prêt
dit quelque chose mathématiquement mais
qu'on ne trouve jamais c'est peut-être
qu'il ya un problème aussi dans notre
calcul ou en tout cas dans notre manière
de poser l'équation belge avait c'est
très compliqué à tous comme ça parce que
par exemple quand on dit si on prédit
quelque chose par le calcul regardez par
exemple
tycho brahe tycho brahé
il est très troublé par le mouvement de
la terre à cause le mouvement d'aidé le
fait qu' il disait par exemple prenez
les étoiles imaginer qu'elle soit des
millions de lieux et bien si la terre
bouge et les étoiles proches devraient
bouger par rapport aux décors c'est un
raisonnement intelligent donc ils
faisaient le calcul vous en regardez un
calcul montre que montre que simplement
ils se trompaient d'un facteur 10 milles
sur lundi sa bonne étoile bondé cause
oui c'est ça c'est à dire que là tout
d'un coup on a un calcul exact avec un
raisonnement qui se tient alors soit
c'est pouvoir parce que cela donnait de
numérique est fausse donc il ya un jeu
là dedans on prédit des trucs ça
s'observe pas alors vous avez un autre
truc qui a occupé l'été les les gens de
la terre des décennies c'est le super
corde
rappelez-vous super cote est tellement
génial alors est ce que est ce que les
supercordes on recense je n'en sais rien
mais voilà intacte piège si moche il est
ce pour lequel que strictement aucune
observation
ouais et supercordes avec quelqu'un on
fabrique les fameuses super chaussettes
oui 5,5 sauf voyez alors on sait plus
très bien quel saint se vouer parce que
regarder par exemple quand la mécanique
quantique était paru vous savez quel
stein disait dieu ne joue pas aux dés
c'est amusant et quelque chose
d'extraordinaire la mécanique point tic
prédisait être le paradoxe d'einstein
podolsky rosen
prenez le fier rosen étaient deux élèves
d'einstein et il a fait des calculs en
montrant si la mécanique quantique tient
debout alors il va se passer ceux ci et
vous savez ce qui se passe va vous avez
un atom qui aimait le photon ces photos
ont des plans de polarisation les plans
de moralisation c'est quand on prend une
corde on peut la faire signer dans un
plan particulier d'engagement là vous
avez un photo qu'il ya aussi comme sage
autres qui aussi comme ça et on prédit
que c'est les plans reste particulière
lorsque j'ai la mécanique quantique
c'est que lorsque vous avez un
feuilleton qui filent comme ça vous
pouvez le faire passer dans une bobine
et asmae ce qu'on appelle l'effet
faraday pour faire tourner le vent de
réalisation alors on fait tourner le
plan pour les jo de photos et lucho
pareil alors comment est-ce que le score
faute on sait que quand il est courant
que comme un des bons acquis soit
informée deux fois qualité de nuit
alors là un style de ski rose lg voilà
ça prouve que la mécanique aux tic
déconne quoi mais ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous avez la
france et que ce n'est pas l'aspect kt
qui a fini par faire l'expérience
il faudrait que ça marche alors oui et
là vraiment il ya une sorte de
dialectique prédire vérifier puis là
vous parler d'un cas où effectivement
c'est l'observation qui va nous amener
justement ça montre une chose c'est que
est ce que notre bon sens et fiable
alors je marche dans les deux sens parce
que voyez pour la mécanique quantique
est d'une absurdité totale et pourquoi
pas ce qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas
modéliser géométriquement il doit y
avoir quelque chose si vous prenez par
la relativité et que vous enlevez la
géométrie cette incompréhensible comme
ça voilà la mécanique quantique un
exhorte d'absurdité croissante quoi donc
est-ce que quel va être le progrès
comment est ce qu'on va faire
vous savez fonction garder en tête c'est
peut-être un jour il y aura encore un
autre changement de paradigme le point
de la localité va peut-être changer
savoir si quelque chose est dedans ou
dehors
prenez par exemple savez ça me fait
penser à un plateau elle son mythe de la
caverne
j'avais de la butte de la caverne mais
ça me sens c'est de voir que des ombres
sur des choses qui nous est chère avec
les terrasses alors imaginez par exemple
qu'on prenne en compte fermé avec un
objet et on le projette sur un écran
vient suivant comment s'est placé le
biais dans la courbe ou à l'extérieur
tout simplement alors pour un
observateur il est dedans pourra nous
serons peut-être la donne c'est comme
les objets géométriques en quatre
dimensions qu'on ne peut pas vraiment se
représenter dans notre dans notre
physique à trois dimensions en tout cas
avec nos moyens de perception naturelles
qui sont empreints d'émotion ce serait
comme de vouloir faire défiler les
solides devant une demande finalement un
être jolie fille qui n'aurait que deux
dimensions
là où on verrait une sphère il verrait
un cercle enfin ce serait pas ce serait
pas possible de le faire représenter
oui par exemple moi j'ai vécu en 1975
c'est cette aventure qui avait commencé
en 67 du retournement de la sphère un
jour je rencontre un mathématicien
aveugle qui vient de mourir
qui
bernard morin et ils avaient modélisé
façon qu'avait une sphère de se
retourner alors ça veut dire quoi vous
prenez une surface sphérique voulait
peiné à se faire en rouge d'un côté et
anvers de l'intérieur m
et le vert sont à l'extérieur voir voilà
exactement comme ça et tu vois j'ai
passé un été à comprendre
voilà quelque chose qui vous massacre
les neurones par contre quand vous
prenez par exemple ce modèle de trou
noir avec tout ce qu'on a vu écrire là
dessus sur l'intérieur du trou noir sur
la sécurité centrale
il n'ya pas d'intérieur c'est là où le
bon sens le sens commun dix ans on est
dans des erreurs
la sens commun qui violent les
mathématiques les mathématiques disent
non oui et là on est en plein le débat
que j'ai vaincu donc ça veut dire que le
rapport entre les mathématiques et le
réel c'est un rapport passionnant
violent contradictoires quelquefois les
mathématiques en raison réelle doit
s'adapter aux mathématiques et quelques
mois c'est le real qui dit non c'est moi
qui ai raison aux mathématiques qui
aiment pas de bouc et vous a même une
chose la plus importante possible c'est
le théorème de grenelle le théorème de
gödel vu que j'avais qui dit tout
langage à une proposition a décidé à bhl
oui hein
et qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
proposition est désirable mais par
exemple si je dis je mens ça veut rien
dire vraiment et non c'est vrai ben ça
c'est faux et dans ce cas la montée par
alors le langage plainte pour vous on
décide à me coller c'est la parabole des
géants subtil et cruelle des concerts a
rappelé la promotion à la connaissance à
gaza sont gênantes
je vais engager un subtil cruel quand un
voyageur arrive sur l'île le fond
prisonniers ils lui disent voilà ce
qu'on va faire tu va nous dire quelque
chose
si c'est vrai on va te laisser partir si
c'est faux on va te mettre à mort et les
titres et vous vous avez le ps va encore
là ils sont pas ils savent plus vraiment
dans la macif
voilà donc des fruits jaunes viennent y
en a plein voilà à ce moment là
il ya des gens qui ont dit oui mais
comme on l attendait des ensembles
appartient n'appartient pas et pas de
problème non on a montré que la torride
d'un sommet était faillible avec le
fameux paradoxe du barbier marié qui
rase tout les gens qui ne se rase pas le
même et c'est alors à ce moment là le
mathématicien lionel s'est dit je vais
essayer de trouver le langage le plus
fondamental
quand on dit c'est simple comme des
défauts 4 ça s'est su civique dj one un
simple alors il a pris le rythme éthique
et en plus dans le haut sens des membres
ordinaires et c'était assez étonnant
c'est le concept de nombres premiers
savez un autre promu talent jusqu'à peu
de diviseur et bien les longues premiers
sont premiers dans n'importe quel
système de numération le nombre 5 et
première base 2 donc il a pris ces
nombres premiers quelques noms en
premier c'est vraiment de la magie parce
qu'ils sont premiers et sur toutes les
planètes de l'univers dans n'importe
quel système à 15 milliards d'années
lumière il ya un type qui sait ce que
c'est qu'un compromis ne sais pas ils
sont en nombre infini d'ailleurs
exactement les voiles c'est quelque
chose de magique donc gaga s'est servi
des nombres premiers pour sortir un peu
de terreau même bizarre et il a cherché
à contrer ce qu'on appelle une logique
dans un langage complet un langage
complet sans lequel il n'y a pas de
problème pas production équitable
donc il a essayé de prendre la halte
nautique définies par les actions de
l'italien qui s'appelle péladeau lui il
a accès aux matiz et arithmétique donc
l'axé mathy ça veut dire que je prends
une machine avec des engrenages des
rouages et je vais tourner une manivelle
et si je dis est ce que un ghana va me
sortir oui bon après je vais dire est ce
que l aile 0 à ce moment là la machine
se met à faire oui non oui donc un égal
zéro nintendo décide à bhl bon à ce
moment là on pourrait dire je vais
rajouter un axiome
mais si je pense que 1 0 est faux alors
je vais démontrer que de également
possible et donc autrement dit même les
mathématiques sont sont construites sur
du sable c'est une ordinaire parce que
là les exemples que vous avez donnée là
des petits paradoxe amusant je précise
quand même pour les spectateurs que
c'est pas juste des paradoxe amusant
pour le coup ça a donné lieu ensuite à
des vrais problèmes mathématiques
difficile à résoudre pour ne pas dire
irrésoluble mais disons que je pense que
nous sommes sur le point d'avoir un
changement de paradigme mathématiques
alors justement j'allais vous en parlais
juste avant parce que j'y ai pensé à
jeter une petite parenthèse un jean
pierre c'est que dans la précédente
question j'ai cité le nom d'etienne
klein pour la question des mathématiques
et si je ne dis pas de bêtises
etienne klein était passé à ce film car
vu la chaîne youtube c'est curieux et la
deuxième fois l'animateur l'avait
demandé à la fin de l'entretien
s'il accepterait de débattre avec vous
sur votre dos dès la nuit il répondu oui
si on m'invite jean pierre petit est ce
que vous voulez interagir avec lui sur
son modèle bien sûr il ya eu des
missions avec débat alors est-ce que
vous avez des nouvelles mais je sais pas
si on peut le dire mais hors micro il a
dit non ah ah bon alors que voter parce
que je vous propose c'est que le dommage
est dommage parce que c'est un garçon
brillant qui explique des tas de choses
à 20 mois en otage alors pour tout ce
que j'ai pu écouter ce que j'arrivais à
suivre sur le plan scientifique puisque
sur le conte philosophique ça allait je
trouve que c'est très très intéressant
ce qu'il dit est certaine les questions
que vous est posée d'ailleurs été un
petit peu on en lien avec certains ces
travaux mais c'est vrai que ce serait
comme je pense très intéressant de vous
avoir en débat et pas forcément au débat
contradictoire non mais en dialogue en
échange parce que je pense que lui son
nobel si je me trompe pas c'est plus
l'épistémologie le temps aussi une
intéresse beaucoup le temps le temps oui
voilà et de la faune des vidéos sur ces
mêmes mais j'annule ceci il pouvait vous
de la façon vous êtes aussi multicartes
c'est à dire qu vous elle vous est
astrophysicien mais vous avez vous avoue
siens un grand intérêt pour la
philosophie dont je pense qu'un dialogue
est possible entre vous donc vers ce que
je fais c'est que je vais lancer un
appel aux internautes
c'est d'extraire la sortie d'une vidéo
et de l'envoyer à etienne klein sur
twitter par exemple
ça il verra de lui proposer un débat en
plus tôt une sitution on verra comment
on appelle ça en terrain neutre que je
me proposerait l'animé étant donné que
ma n'ayant pas les compétences de toutes
façons pour prendre parti pour l'un ou
pour l'autre
je pourrais simplement faire la joie des
spectateurs c'est à dire d'essayer de
rendre tous incompréhensible pour le
commun donc vous ce que vous seriez
d'accord
bien sûr mais twitter ce serait
absolument pas à débat conflictuel
non parce que c'est votre nature non je
dire que la philosophie est elle un
échange d'idées on n'est pas là en train
de se jeter des croyances à la figure il
faut aller d'un décès date le religieux
pour faire ça ouais je pense enfin bon
je pense que je le perçois avec avec une
certaine dimension d'ouverture d'esprit
d'après ce que j'ai pu voir de huit dont
je pense que ce serait très très très
très bon on assiste à une vidéo qu'il a
fait ou il est à l'intérieur d'un petit
laboratoire lui à côté d'une lunette et
il dit la chose suivante ça leur montée
a déjà deux trois ans soit on arrivera à
identifier cette matière sombre soit
alors on sera obligé de remettre en
cause les modèles théoriques qui nous
permettent de comprendre le réel il a
tout dit quoi
l'appel est lancé s'il s'avérait que
nous n'avons aucune trace expérimental
de leur réalité
il faudra mettre le doute cette fois non
pas sur la réalité mais sur la théorie
qui prétendent à décrire et la question
est qui va céder en premier
la théorie ou la réalité alors j'ai une
question en lien avec les mathématiques
c'est une question qui va être vous
paraître un peu idiote mais après tout
pourquoi pas parce que on en a déjà
parlé un petit peu l'acteur mais cette
punition à bulles spéculatives
si on admet que les lois physiques qui
régissent l'univers sont de nature
mathématiques est ce que ça signifie que
la réciproque est vraie autrement dit
est-ce qu'il se pourrait que tout ce qui
est mathématiquement possible soit
physiquement réel disons qu'il ya des
choses qui sont mathématiquement
possible kisob qui se sont révélées être
rêve
il ya des choses qui sont réels qui sont
révélés en contradiction avec avec les
mathématiques
donc il ya des interactions c'est à dire
que de temps en temps les mathématiques
mais il faut changer la vision du réel
et en toile à elle dit il faut changer
la terre peuvent aussi en mathématiques
donc oui ça s'appelle la dialectique qui
pensent et alors moi j'ai un exemple
j'aurais les anglais je dis ça pourquoi
est ce que j'ai l'impression que enfin
pareil c'est un réflexe de novices de
nom scientifique de me dire qu'on a
développé des mathématiques finalement
assez complexe alors complexe parution
ce mathématiques complexes notion ce
courant du terme et se dire que
finalement on a utilisé toutes ces
théories mathématiques pour décrypter le
réel leur est physique est jolie mais
finalement pour pression devrait
s'arrêter à racine carrée puissance et
c'est pourquoi est ce que par exemple
les noms des imaginaires ne pourrait pas
être convoqué aussi pour expliquer
certains phénomènes physiques alors on
va me dire que par définition si c'est
l'imaginaire séparée elle puisqu'il ya
des nombreux réel qui voit là mais
qu'est ce qui l'en empêche
je veux dire ce que l'autre pense me
croyez que c'est pas une deuxième vidéo
c'est parce qu'elle vous êtes un trader
une boîte de pandore starbucks pour
maintenance
spectateurs jeune roi jeu probablement
une deuxième vidéo absolument un souffle
et de donner un petit peu loin la bouche
ou est ce qu'on peut faire et qu'on
garde ça plus tard bah oui je peux le
donner l'eau à la bouche
disons que qu'est ce qui crée les
concepts de masse les concepts de
rayonnement et c'est bon mais comme vous
voyez un homme comme sur you le
mathématicien et bien moi je trouve
qu'il a eu une approche passionnante en
dix ans donnez moi un espace et sa
structure je vous dirai ce qu'il
contient alors à ce point là bas quand
on prend l'espace euclidien et bien ce
mois là c'est là dedans peut se déplacer
avec des rotations des translations et
ce moment là sur you avec une méthode
mathématique tout à fait clair dit et
bien dans cet espace il ya des droits
qui a des plans et des cercles la dé ce
fait les syllabes des hélices très bien
alors ensuite si on se donne un espace
temps quelle dimension mais qu'est-ce
qui habite cet espace temps vers ce sont
des mouvements sont des particules les
particules sont décrites par leur
mouvement
alors il ya dans une phase 2015 ce qui
les basses et puis les charges loyer
calculé les masses et puis les pelotons
mais là où c'est intéressant c'est que
cette matrice secrète des masses
négative et des photos d'énergie
négative
c'est doux c'est de là qu'est partie que
tout développement de janus maintenant
si on décide tout d'un coup que l'espace
dans lequel on vit est un espace de
ermite bien à ce moment-là il a des
masses réel et des masses imaginer des
masses complexe et à ce moment là on a
un déploiement de quelque chose je lis
une étape vers visage et une très bonne
amie qui s'appelle la télé de black et
battait madrid qui est belge et qui
bataille beaucoup avec moi pour publier
dans ce domaine là donc elle a fait tout
un travail d alger du coup de poing car
elle s'était alors voici une revue qui a
beaucoup de mal à trouver à la chérie et
finalement la revue lui a écrit
lee addy votre travail comme ça donne
des masses imaginaire c'est pas de la
physique
alors là on pourrait dire la mécanique
quantique peut imaginer l adema tous les
coins de rue des marais rome -
poursuivre sur rendez vous voilà on
demandé alors on arrive à la dernière
question de cet entretien jean pierre
petit sid el chose une seule chose que
vous souhaiteriez que les gens
retiennent de votre parcours
qu'est ce que ce serait une seule chose
comme j'aimerais que les genres côté du
parcours bien remettez tout en question
c'est tout voilà c'est ce que je dirai à
des étudiants ne prenez pas comme argent
comptant tout ce que j'avais appris
l'université vous savez il ya une chose
amusante quelquefois il ya des gens qui
disent mais comment trouver les idées
c'est très simple vous prenez un bouquin
regardez par exemple un magnifique
boucane cosmologique comme ça là vous
l'ouvrez vie vous cherchez la wii avec
luc louis des niveaux raisonnables
suppose et mous dit qu'est ce qui se
passe je ne suis pas raisonnable pouvait
il peut être inverse
et là vous avez tout un sur glace qui se
déploie c'est tout donc apprenez on peut
être raisonnable apprenez remet tout en
question
voilà merci vous aurez choisi
[Musique]
ans
oh